well the battle against the coronavirus
is not going to be ending anytime soon
if you've been following the numbers you
know that not only are the numbers in
the United States in general really not
looking good disproportionately so of
course among the unvaccinated but we
also have some states that are at their
pandemic Peaks now their pandemic Peaks
now in terms of daily cases they are in
pandemic Peaks now in terms of total
hospitalizations and the death numbers
are going very much in the wrong
direction again mostly unvaccinated
people but there is this question of
what about the vaccinated because there
is no question that we are seeing
breakthrough cases which are mostly mild
but we're seeing breakthrough
hospitalizations as well although
relatively fewer in number and we're
seeing breakthrough deaths as well and
there's early data from Israel
showing that it starts to seem it seems
as though it starts maybe around five
six months and then there's a noticeable
drop off at the eighth eight month Mark
that there is declining uh efficacy in
these vaccines and so the question of a
third booster dose has been raised uh
over the last several weeks and month
and we now have heard from the CDC the
U.S will begin wide distribution of
covet booster shots next month
saying vaccine protection wanes over
time there's a good write-up about this
on CNBC and these are third doses third
doses for people who have already had
two doses of moderna or two doses of
Pfizer like I and many of you in the
audience have as well
the article writes the U.S will start
widely Distributing covet booster shots
next month as new data shows vaccine
protection wanes over time top U.S
health officials announced Wednesday it
is now quote very clear that immunity
starts to fall after the initial two
doses and with the dominance of the
Delta variant quote we are starting to
see evidence of reduced protection
against mild and moderate disease
according to the statement signed by CDC
director Rachelle wolenski let's go now
to Rochelle wolenski speaking yesterday
and listen to what she had to say
through the end of July and early August
three points are now very clear first
vaccine-induced protection against SARS
cov2 infection begins to decrease over
time now important she's talking there
about infection now next she will talk
about the other elements second vaccine
Effectiveness against severe disease
hospitalization and death remains
relatively High yes and third vaccine
Effectiveness is generally decreased
against the Delta variant so let's jump
into the data on this slide you will see
two studies one from New York and one an
analysis of data from the Mayo Clinic
from May 3rd through July 25th New York
examined covid-19 tests and linked them
to individuals vaccination status based
on the state's vaccine records this is
huge this allowed New York to study
vaccine Effectiveness against infection
over time for more than 10 million New
Yorkers of all ages
vaccine Effectiveness in May during as
early during the vaccine rollout in the
state was 92 percent
in the later months further from
vaccination vaccine Effectiveness
declined to 80 percent these data will
be published in the mmwr today
the Mayo Clinic analysis looked at
vaccine Effectiveness for both the
Pfizer and moderna vaccines okay so what
is the point here the point here is over
time efficacy wanes and um there's
really two aspects to this and this is
re we don't know the answer to this but
this is a really important thing to
understand
the efficacy in the real world
is in part waning because the virus
variant that is dominant now is not the
one that the vaccine was developed
against this is different than vaccine
efficacy goes down against the live
variant the original variant against
which the vaccines were were designed it
may or it may not but we don't yet have
reason to believe that and so this may
well become
like a flu shot type situation where I'm
scheduled to get my flu shot in a few
days myself the flu shot I will get in a
few days is based on what was believed
to be the dominant strain at the time
that this year's flu shot started to be
developed I don't know if it's six or
eight months ago
and depending on how well that matches
what's actually out there in this
upcoming flu season I will have a lower
or higher degree of protection and
similarly uh when we talk about the
covid-19 vaccine the uh same same
question applies which is how uh how how
closely does the variant that is
dominant match what the vaccines were
designed for so this is this is where we
are going and uh the the guidance as as
far as we understand it now
is going to be starting eight months
after your second dose of the Pfizer or
moderna vaccine
for me I received my second dose
February 26th so I would become eligible
um on October 26th and if that's the
case and the vaccine is available I will
go and get a third shot because I want
to not only protect myself but protect
people around me
um there are of course people who have
not gotten any vaccine and don't plan to
who are going to take this as an
opportunity to say now I'm definitely
not getting the vaccine even though they
already definitely weren't getting the
vaccine because they will say this is
just part of the plot to get us more and
more and more doses forever well when
something becomes endemic like flu
that's the way it will sometimes work
and that's the way it does work with flu
so of course people who want to see a
conspiracy will see one anywhere they
want they will see it in evidence and
they will see it in the absence of
evidence and these are not really good
faith actors that we can deal with in
any serious way but this is where we are
right now and many people are feeling
and understandably so will this ever
friend
like is this ever going to go away and
the answer is it may not ever go away as
an endemic thing that is just
circulating with Peaks and valleys sort
of like flu
but if we get enough people vaccinated
and eventually it seems likely we would
have a reformulated vaccine tailored to
maybe the Delta variant maybe to a
variant that is still sometime in the
future we can get it under control from
the standpoint of it being a pandemic
but uh certainly you know things like
masks on planes have been extended until
January at minimum until January we are
starting to see vaccine requirements at
increasingly in different cities and
states to go to restaurants to go to
indoor venues this this stuff is not
going to end anytime soon and of course
part of the reason is a whole bunch of
people still are not interested in
getting vaccinated at least one doctor
and I'm going to talk about this next is
saying he will no longer treat
unvaccinated patients
when we're talking about sleep we always
hear about how much sleep people get but
often neglected in the conversation is
the quality of that sleep which is just
as important and science shows that
lowering your body temperature during
sleep can help you be more rested and
Achieve better sleep and that's where
our sponsor chili sleep comes in chili
sleep makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions to
help you improve your sleep comes in two
varieties the uler Sleep System and the
cube Sleep System that's what I have on
my bed both are hydropowered temperature
controlled luxury mattress pads you can
make your bed as cold as 55 degrees I
choose 60. you can make it as hot as 115
degrees if that's your thing I don't
feel hot anymore at night no more
sweating I'm sleeping better and I love
it I also have the chili sleep chili
blanket which helps keep me cool on top
as well they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to
chiliesleep.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video